je suis heureux de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour entendre monsieur
jean-françois montel candidats
pressentis pour exercer les fonctions de
président du directoire de
l'établissement public société du grand
paris
cette audition est prévue par l'article
8 de la loi du 3 juin 2010 relative au
grand paris en application de cette loi
le président du directoire est en effet
nommé par décret après avis du conseil
de surveillance qui vient tout juste de
se tenir en visioconférence et après
audition devant les commissions
permanentes compétentes du parlement
il ne s'agit pas à proprement d'une
audition régie dans le cadre de
l'article 13 de la constitution
à la différence d'autres candidats
pressentis les la différence est ici
qu'un vote avec nos collègues députés
pour approuver sa nomination n'est pas
requis pour autant nous sommes là pour
vous entendez jouer notre rôle
il est envisagé de vous nommer moins de
trois ans seulement après la nomination
de monsieur thierry d'allah qui n'aura
pas été jusqu'au bout de son mandat de
cinq ans d'ailleurs si ma mémoire est
bonne ça n'a été le cas d'aucun de ses
prédécesseurs puisque depuis la création
d'établissements 2010 4 et bientôt cinq
présidents de directoire se sont succédé
de lundi fut relevé
vous comprendrez que cette instabilité
nous interroge
voir nous inquiète quant à la bonne
conduite du projet du grand paris
express venant d'ailleurs au projet lui
même la société du grand paris express
est chargé de la conception et de la
réalisation de transport public est basé
sur la construction d'ici 2030 ce projet
d'infrastructure d'un réseau de 200 km
de voies nouvelles avec notamment le
prolongement de la ligne 14 et la
création de quatre lignes nouvelles
les lignes 15 16 17 et 18 et 2,68 gare
cela correspond à un doublement du
réseau existant
l'objectif est notamment de désengorger
le réseau actuel est de faciliter les
trajets de banlieue à banlieue
il doit s'accompagner d'importantes
retombées socioéconomiques que vous
pourrez d'ailleurs nous rappeler le
projet a néanmoins connu de nombreuses
dérives et rive à la fois en termes de
coût et en termes de calendrier sur les
coûts d'abord comme l'ont récemment mis
en lumière nos collègues de la
commission des finances qui ont publié
en octobre 2020 un rapport intitulé
grand paris express des coups à
maîtriser un financement à consolider la
société du grand paris a traversé une
crise d'ampleur en 2018
à la suite de la publication d'un
rapport de la cour des comptes qui a mis
en avant la dérive des coûts du projet
qui sont passés je vous le rappelle
entre 2013 et 2017 de 22,6 milliards à
31,5 à 35,1 milliards d'euros ensuite
sur le calendrier ci chantier a débuté
dès juillet 2016
il connaît d'importants retards qui
s'explique en partie par la crise
sanitaire de telle sorte que jean
baptiste djebbari a annoncé en juin 2020
que les lignes 16 et 17 ne serait pas
prête pour les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 en tant que
conseiller maître à la cour des comptes
vous connaissez parfaitement ces
problématiques de dérive de coût et de
calendrier
c'est pourquoi nous souhaiterions vous
entendent aussi précisément que possible
sur votre feuille de route pour la suite
du projet avant de vous laisser la
parole pour un propos liminaire puis à
l'ensemble de mes collègues qui auront
j'en suis certain un grand nombre de
questions à vous poser
je souhaitais vous interroger sur deux
points précis
d'une part le modèle de financement du
projet qui toujours d'après nos
collègues de la commission des finances
a atteint ses limites
partagez vous ce constat est d'après
vous ce modèle devrait-il à terme
évoluer
d'autre part le rapport de nos collègues
pointait les progrès qui restent à
accomplir dans les relations entre la
ngp et les autres organismes de
transport francilien au premier rang
desquels ile de france mobilité qui sera
en charge de l'exploitation du réseau
quelles sont vos propositions en la
matière je vous remercie et je vous
souhaite tout de suite la parole
merci place la barre très haut
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
je remercie votre commission de
m'entendre cet après midi dans le cadre
du processus de désignation prévu par la
loi de 2010 que vous venez d'évoquer
monsieur le président pour répondre à
votre propos d'introduction j'évoquerai
d'abord mon analyse de la situation
actuelle s'agissant du projet grand
paris express
et s'agissant de la société du grand
paris
puis je vous dirais quelques mots de mon
parcours et des moyens que j'entends
mobilisés pour mener à bien ce projet
j'essaierai évidemment de répondre aux
deux questions que je vous m'avez
adressées à l'instant alors pour la
deuxième fois de ma carrière je me
trouve devant la possibilité de mettre
en oeuvre un projet à la naissance
duquel j'ai initialement participer
membre du cabinet du premier ministre en
2009 et 2010 en charge notamment du
développement durable et des transports
j'ai participé aux réflexions d'abord
aux décisions ensuite qui devait
déboucher entre autres sur la loi du 3
juin 2010 relative au grand paris ou sur
le décret du 7 juillet 2010 relatif à la
société du grand paris
je rappelle ces points parce qu'ils sont
très importants pour la suite et en
particulier pour la conception que je me
fais de la cohérence de ce projet je
vais y revenir
participer à un projet à la naissance
duquel on a concouru n'est pas une
situation si fréquentes pour reprendre
ce que disait d'ailleurs monsieur le
premier ministre le 14 décembre dernier
en inaugurant le prolongement nord de la
ligne 14
première mise en service des lignes
constitutive du grand paris express
aussi en entamant ce propos je veux
d'abord vous dire que pour quelqu'un qui
a consacré sa vie professionnelle au
service de la chose publique
passant d'un grand plan exceptionnel
d'investissement régional à la
réorganisation de l'état territorial ou
de la restructuration d'un ministère à
l'analyse de la situation financière des
départements entrer de plain-pied dans
la mise en oeuvre concrète et
opérationnelle du grand paris express à
la naissance duquel à nouveau j'ai
participé c'est d'abord entrer dans un
projet qui réussit ce projet vous l'avez
rappelé a déjà connu depuis 11 ans une
histoire riche avec des difficultés des
recalages et d adaptation
j'y reviendrai bien sûr mais aussi et
surtout des réussites qu'illustre
l'inauguration que je mentionnais à
l'instant et qui illustre surtout de
très nombreuses avancées probablement
moins immédiatement visible mais qui
démontre déjà la capacité de la société
du grand paris à le conduire ce projet
connaîtra évidemment encore de
nombreuses vicissitudes
c'est le lot de tous grands projets
publics des temps modernes et on peut
même aisément conjecturer que les
difficultés seront à la hauteur de
l'ambition mais ce projet ira au bout et
c'est d'abord avec cette conviction que
je me présente devant vous cet après
midi
aussi en débutant ce propos vous me
permettrait de rappeler le souvenir de
cette période au cours de laquelle s'est
concrétisé cet immense ambition et
d'évoquer les acteurs de cette époque et
enfin de vous dire à nouveau que c'est
dans cette ambition que je m'inscrirai
alors que dire aujourd'hui du projet et
de l'ambition les deux premiers
paragraphes de la loi de 2010 les
définissent et rappelle que le projet
d'ensemble s'appuie sur la création d'un
réseau de transport public de voyageurs
vous avez mentionné monsieur le
président la question de la création de
rigeur richesse comme vous j'ai pris
connaissance des études préliminaires
d'ailleurs qui évoque des chiffres que
je ne qualifierais pas de vertigineux
mais extrêmement important de l'ordre de
100 à 200 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires générés par ce grand
projet en tout cas c'est à cette aune
que se mesure l'ambition d'ailleurs les
superlatifs sont de mise dès qu'on
évoque le grand paris express le réseau
de transport de même d'ailleurs que les
comparaisons voire parfois
l'impossibilité d'en établir
je ne me livrerai pas à ces superlatifs
d'abord parce que je crois que ces
appréciations si juste soit elles sont
derrière nous alors que a bien débuté la
phase de réalisation
ensuite parce que cette participation à
ce qu'on a appelé le chantier du siècle
si elle justifie une mobilisation
exceptionnelle de ses acteurs ne doit
pas non plus tétanisée qu'est-ce qui
doit aujourd'hui être mis en avant selon
moi j'userai de trois qualificatifs qui
dicteront mon action le grand paris
express c'est d'abord un projet
indispensable
ce dont il s'agit ce n'est pas seulement
de creuser des tunnels ni même de
permettre à des trains de rouler à une
vitesse d'ailleurs jusqu'ici inconnu
pour un équipement de ce type ce dont il
s'agit en définitive c'est d'améliorer
la vie des gens c'est de réduire les
déséquilibres territoriaux c'est de
conforter la trajectoire et les
engagements français en matière de
développement durable et de lutte contre
les effets du changement climatique
comme me le disait il ya trois jours le
président d'un conseil départemental
particulièrement concernés ce projet
redessine les cartes et annonce enfin le
désenclavement si nécessaire de nombreux
territoires d'île de france
j'ajoute enfin que dans une période si
difficile que nous vivons tous depuis
bientôt un an
ce projet est aussi la manifestation de
l'espoir dans l'avenir tout à la fois
dans la capacité de notre pays à
conduire un chantier de cette ampleur
est notre souhait collectif de retrouver
puis développer des échanges entre les
hommes qui ne soit pas seulement
virtuelles un projet indispensable donc
mais aussi et je veux d'emblée insisté
là dessus un projet cohérent
l'ambition initiale du grand paris que
tous les gouvernements depuis 2010 sont
confirmées ce n'est pas de proposer une
série de tronçons détachable les uns des
autres qu'on réalisera séparément au gré
des moyens qu'on abandonnerait tour à
tour au gré des difficultés ou des
oppositions
c'est un réseau que l'article 2 de la
loi de 2010 définit dans toute sa
cohérence interne et ses interconnexions
avec l'ensemble des réseaux existants et
que le schéma d'ensemble votée à
l'unanimité par le conseil de
surveillance de la société du grand
paris est approuvée par le décret du 24
août 2011 traduit la cohérence de
l'ensemble du réseau s'inscrit dans une
cohérence plus globale encore de
l'ensemble des aménagements induit avec
les 68 garer leurs quartiers futur pôle
de développement de requalification
urbaine et de potentialités qui sont
loin à l'évidence d'avoir été tout
envisager mais c'est là que se situe le
potentiel de développement que vous
mentionniez monsieur le président en
introduction le grand paris express
enfin se caractérise depuis ses débuts
comme un projet collectif
la concertation a présidé à toutes les
étapes préalables à l'entrée dans la
phase opérationnelle où nous sommes
aujourd'hui elle se poursuit depuis lors
au niveau local comme à celui du
pilotage d'ensemble et me semble une des
conditions essentielles à la réussite du
projet ainsi par exemple
entré dans la phase industrielle que
j'évoquais le grand paris express ne
saurait manquer d'apparaître et cela a
déjà commencé d'ailleurs comme une
source de nuisance avant que d'être ce
grand réseau de transport public qui
fera que les gens vivront mieux dès à
présent gérer cet impact territorial qui
apportent les inconvénients
avant de laisser entrevoir les avantages
même si tout est mis en oeuvre
d'après ce que j'ai pu entrevoir pour
limiter les nuisances ne peut se faire
qu'en concertation étroite et permanente
avec les élus cette appréhension
collective et concertée du projet dans
sa conception et dans sa conduite
s'exerce à tous les niveaux relations
avec les élus je les dis et bien entendu
avec les services de l'état en
particulier sur les questions d'un pacte
territorial mais aussi rôle déterminant
joué par le conseil de surveillance de
la société du grand paris organes
délibérants doté de larges prérogatives
et enfin j'y reviendrai caractère
collégial du directoire en bref c'est
cette mobilisation collective de toutes
les énergies s'appuyant sur un exercice
de concertation et de transparence
permanent qui fait la marque de fabrique
du grand paris est la condition de son
succès où en est le projet aujourd'hui
il n'est pas inutile je crois de
rappeler succinctement quelques étapes
2010 lois décrets débat public 2011
schéma d'ensemble 2012 à 2016 études
première déclaration d'utilité publique
maîtrise foncière 2016-2017 bouclage des
déclarations d'utilité publique
début des travaux de génie civil arrivée
des premiers tunnelier alors certes il
sera question
cet après midi et bien souvent ensuite
des délais des retards mais je tiens
quand même à souligner ses premières
étapes et ce calendrier
trois l'ont d'ailleurs pour rappeler
avant tout que si retard
il y a eu aujourd'hui et s'ils ont pu
être constatés notamment dans la phase
2017-2018 que je vais mentionné dans un
instant
c'est des retards probablement par
rapport à une estimation initiale qui
n'étaient pas bonnes mais aujourd'hui le
grand paris express se sont toutes les
lignes en travaux plus d'une centaine de
chantiers en cours 7000 personnes qui
s'y emploient quotidiennement ses 40 km
de tunnels sur 200 déjà creusé c'est une
série d'émission obligataire couronnée
de succès c'est enfin il ya quelques
jours et pour prendre ces seul exemple
l'attribution du marché de réseaux
multiservices des lignes 15 16 et 17
c'est la publication de l'appel public à
concurrence du deuxième marché de la
ligne 15 ouest en conception réalisation
bref pour arriver à ces résultats
concrets le projet est la société du
grand paris sont passés par un certain
nombre de crises et ont déjà traversé ce
qui n'a rien d'anormal je le redis pour
un tel projet des difficultés
importantes
je voudrais souligner toutefois qu'à mes
yeux une de ces crises vous l'avez
d'ailleurs mentionné monsieur le
président paraît fondatrice et constitue
probablement un tournant majeur dans la
jeune histoire du projet je pense à
celle de début 2018 la suite de certains
signaux d'alert et d'un rapport que vous
avez évoqué fin 2017 de la cour des
comptes le coût du projet a été ré
estimés les plannings ajusté et la
priorisation de ces travaux redéfinit le
tout le tout sans que la consistance du
projet soit modifié pour faire face à
ces bouleversements les moyens de
l'opérateur ont été recalibré sa
stratégie redessiner son modèle
financier adapté
je reviendrai évidemment sur la question
du modèle financier sur laquelle vous
m'avez interrogées alors en plus des
superlatifs que j'ai renoncé à rappeler
en commençant je crois qu'il faut
rajouter un autre très atypique pour un
projet de cette ampleur
qui est cet épisode d'aggiornamento
franc et massif significatif avant tout
de la volonté politique qui le porte
cela suscite pour moi deux remarques
supplémentaires s'agissant des coûts
cette réévaluation de 2018 et
manifestement robuste depuis
l'évaluation de la cour fin 2017 et l'
expertise qui a été ensuite déclenché en
jusqu'à la dernière évaluation figurant
dans le rapport d'information de votre
assemblée d'octobre dernier que vous
mentionniez monsieur le président est
bien entre ces deux dates il n'y a pas
d'évolution réellement significative
deuxième remarque en franchissant cet
obstacle de 2018 le projet d'ensemble a
démontré sa solidité
ce que je veux simplement souligner ce
n'est pas que le grand paris est
désormais à l'abri des crises ou les
difficultés bien évidemment mais qu'il a
démontrées et c'est pour moi beaucoup
plus important qu'il avait la capacité à
les surmonter
où en est la société du grand paris
quant à elles deux remarques on regarde
évidemment des éléments d'information
dont je peux disposer à ce stade et je
sais que vous me pardonnerai de ne pas
pouvoir rentrer dans tous les détails
ayant jusqu'ici une familiarité limitée
avec un terme de cette société les
effectifs de la société du grand paris
ont connu une croissance exponentielle
notamment à partir du tournant de 2018
il s'élève aujourd'hui à 750 personnes
je rappelle qu'à l'arrivée de mon en tes
prédécesseurs
le chiffre était inférieur à 130 en 2014
l'objectif est d'atteindre 1000
personnes à la fin de cette année au
titre d'ailleurs des enjeux majeurs de
la société du grand paris dans le proche
avenir
l'intégration fluide de ses nouveaux
collaborateurs et la capacité à leurs
données aussi vite que possible une
plaine opérationnalité me paraissent
déterminant à ce titre et ce n'est sans
doute pas la dernière fois que je les
voc les difficultés supplémentaires
occasionnés par les mesures mises en
place pour faire face à la crise
pandémique paraissent un moyen d'un
point d'attention pardon extrêmement
important
deuxième remarque la crédibilité
démontré par la société du grand paris
sur les marchés financiers est un atout
évident à consolider elle conforte la
stratégie de sécurisation du financement
à bakou validé par le conseil de
surveillance est mentionné également
dans le dernier rapport du sénat
quelques mots maintenant si vous me le
permettez pour me présenter mon parcours
au cours des trente dernières années est
inégalement partagée entre des fonctions
de contrôle pour une douzaine d'années
environ et des fonctions opérationnelles
pour environ 18 ans il est également
inégalement partagée entre des fonctions
au niveau central également pour une
douzaine d'années et des fonctions au
niveau territorial également pour 18 ans
même si je n'y ai jamais directement
exercer je pense pouvoir dire que j'ai
consacré plus de 13 ans de ma vie
professionnelle aux collectivités
territoriales comme sous préfet ou
secrétaire général aux affaires
régionales ou alors dernièrement pour
les contrôler si mes fonctions au sein
des juridictions financières et mon
corps d'origine
mon évidemment prédisposé à la culture
du bon emploi des fonds publics pour
reprendre une expression que j'aime
beaucoup
j'ai également exercé les fonctions
d'ordonnateur soit pour des programmes
support du ministère de la transition
écologique pour prendre sa dernière
dénomination soit indirectement pour un
important programme exceptionnel
d'investissement régional dont j'étais
le responsable local j'ai donc pu
expérimenter ce que sont les contraintes
et les enjeux de la dépense publique et
surtout ceux qui en permet l'utilité
au-delà de ces quelques éléments
biographiques je souhaiterais maintenant
aborder sans détour
deux questions elles me sont inspirés
d'abord des premières réactions que j'ai
pu recueillir des premières questions
qui m'ont été posées et est également de
ce que j'ai pu lire dans la presse
spécialisée
elles me sont inspirés également par le
fait que je les crois légitime
premièrement mon arrivée à la présidence
du directoire de la société du grand
paris signifie telle une rupture dans la
conduite du projet deuxièmement n'ayant
jamais dirigé d'entreprise ni creuser
des tunnels avec quelle expérience tirée
de mon parcours
puis je prétendre faire face aux défis
nombreux posés à la société du grand
paris
première question rupture ou continuité
même si une telle question est toujours
un peu théorique elle est gelée
d'illégitime
celui-ci vous là qu'on pouvait même allé
jusqu'à interpréter mon statut de
magistrat financier pour en tirer des
conclusions sur des intentions cachées
dont je préfère dire tout de suite
qu'elles sont imaginaires il me semble
d'abord que cette question néglige un
point très important qui permet de la
relativiser très largement je veux à
nouveau parler du caractère collégial de
la gouvernance au delà du rôle du
conseil de surveillance que j'ai
mentionnés je rappelle que le directoire
est lui-même collégiale et qu'au moment
où ma propre nomination est proposé le
renouvellement des deux autres membres
du directoire
présent à la société du grand paris
depuis respectivement 2015 et 2017 est
également proposé c'est un gage parmi
d'autres de la continuité de ce projet
et de sa conduite au delà de ce premier
élément
je souhaite être très clair sur ce see
la société du grand paris a pris sous
l'impulsion de son conseil de
surveillance et la proposition de son
directoire
un certain nombre de décisions
stratégiques qui me paraissent
déterminante pour la réussite du projet
je m'appuierai dessus et je mettrai tout
en oeuvre pour les conforter et en tirer
tout le profit possible pour donner
quelques exemples je pense en
particulier à cette sécurisation des
flux financiers qui permettent dès à
présent de faire face aux besoins de
décaissement jusqu'en 2027 environ je
pense au passage à la conception
réalisation sur les marchés de la ligne
15 est et de la ligne 15 ouest
je pense à la mise en place d'un
dispositif renforcé de gestion des
risques
sous le contrôle en particulier du
comité d'audit et des engagements
du conseil de surveillance ainsi qu'à
bien d'autres tous ses choix conforte
encore s'il en était besoin la
consistance la continuité et la solidité
du projet je recevrai à mon arrivée une
lettre de mission du premier ministre
qui au delà des objectifs précis qui me
seront assignés confortera cette
trajectoire
deuxième question quelles sont les
expériences tirées de mon parcours que
je compte mobiliser pour faire face aux
différents défis qui attendent la
société du grand paris
à la tête d'une entité de bientôt mille
personnes
l'énonciation de capacités particulières
dans tel ou tel domaine technique n'a
pas à mon sens véritablement de sens
le sujet est d'abord managériale pour le
conduire mon expérience du dialogue avec
les élus et l'ensemble des services de
l'état
celle que j'ai tiré de mes fonctions
cabinets ministériels ou en
administration centrale mais aussi
celles que je tire de mes fonctions de
président du conseil d'administration
d'un établissement public puisque
j'exerce cette mission à l'office
français pour la protection des réfugiés
et apatrides me seront évidemment très
utile j'ai bien évidemment conscience
d'arriver dans un contexte qui n'est pas
simple avec des enjeux majeurs à la fois
sur le projet dans sa globalité sur sa
continuité sur sa conduite mais aussi
pour chacune de ses composantes
composantes tronçon par tronçon
pourrait-on dire je ne sous estime pas
encore une fois les difficultés mais je
ne veux pas non plus en être paralysés
la société du grand paris est maintenant
un maître ouvrage très importante doter
de moyens conséquents qu'il s'agit
d'abord de faire fonctionner au sein de
son écosystème nationales et locales en
valorisant ce qui commence à apparaître
comme sa culture d'entreprise à savoir
technicité concertation transparence et
adaptabilité
ainsi en première analyse il me semble
que la clé des succès à venir réside
dans l' équilibre l'equilibre entre des
objectifs aux exigences qui sans être
contradictoires doivent en permanence
être conciliées je pense en particulier
à l' équilibre entre la conduite
opérationnelle au quotidien et le
pilotage stratégique l équilibre entre
le management d'une entité qui comptera
près de mille salariés dans un an et le
dialogue constant avec l'ensemble des
partenaires externes équilibre enfin
entre la cohérence globale du projet
d'ensemble et la faculté d'adaptation
qui doit caractériser un projet de ce
type
cette cohérence d'ensemble je le redis
est probablement une des leçons les plus
fortes que je tire de mon expérience
dans les débuts du grand paris et je
serai le garant de sa préservation
les priorités qui sont celles de la
société du grand paris aujourd'hui ne
changeront pas la sécurité sur les
chantiers de celles et ceux qui
travaillent des riverains des agents la
fiabilité et la capacité à délivrer
comme on dit est donc avant tout la
maîtrise des risques
la maîtrise enfin des coûts et de la
trajectoire financière
je retire de mes premiers et rapide
contact l'impression d'un établissement
tendu vers l'objectif et mobilisant
dorénavant un impressionnant panel de
compétences
j'en tire aussi la certitude que
l'ensemble des partenaires de la société
du grand paris partage avec elle
cette volonté d'aboutir et de remplir
cet objectif d'intérêt national dont
parle la loi de 2010 cette mobilisation
collective est sans doute une des
caractéristiques les plus fortes du
grand paris et comme toute entreprise
collective
ce projet devra je le dis une dernière
fois surmontée encore bien des
vicissitudes et bien des difficultés
mais les surmonter me paraît une tâche
enthousiasmante quand elle est mise au
service d'un projet fondateur c'est pour
y contribuer que je suis devant vous
cet après midi quelques mots sur les
questions que vous m'avez posé monsieur
le président si je
j'essaie d'y répondre tout de suite
premièrement sur la question du modèle
de financement et son éventuelle
évolution
quelques éléments de rappel en vous
priant mais ce ne sera sans doute pas là
non plus la dernière fois que je le
ferai au cours de cette séance de
pardonner mais imprécisions à un moment
où je commence à appréhender l'ampleur
du dossier et où je n'ai pas encore pu
avoir avec les équipes en place les
échanges suffisant pour alimenter mon
propos alors ce modèle financier je le
rappelle il est dessiné par la loi il
est composé de deux éléments le rapport
le dernier rapport d'octobre 2020 du
sénat le mentionne des recettes
d'origine fiscale d'abord et la capacité
d'emprunt
ensuite les recettes d'origine fiscale
représente 750 millions d'euros par an
quand les dépenses en rythme de
croisière s'élèveront à 3 à 4 milliards
d'euros par an en phase de réalisation
nous y sommes déjà
la conclusion de tout ceci est simple la
société du grand paris fonctionne à ce
stade
grâce à sa capacité d'emprunt et
constitue de la dette publique
laquelle doit être évidemment contrôlée
par le parlement et voir sa
soutenabilité garantie
c'est évidemment sur cette question de
la soutenabilité de la dette dont je
rappelle qu'elle avait déjà été mise en
avant dans le rapport de 2010 est de la
cour des comptes que la question du
modèle de financement continuera d'être
posée je rappelle aussi que le modèle
d'amortissement tel qu'il est
actuellement prévu débouche sur un
amortissement complet en 2070 au moment
où je m'apprête si je suis confirmé à
rentrer dans ces fonctions vous
comprenez vous comprendrez aisément
qu'il serait sans doute présomptueux de
ma part de vous tracer les voies et
moyens précis qui entre 2060 et 2070
permettront
de boucler ce modèle de financement est
ce que je veux souligner c'est que le
tournant de 2018 que j'ai déjà maintes
fois évoqué a aussi été un tournant
important sur cette question là à la
suite du rapport de la cour des comptes
à la suite d'un rapport interne qui
avait été réalisé par don d'un rapport
externe qui avait été commandée par la
société du grand paris en 2018
la feuille de route a été tracée par le
premier ministre en février 2018 si je
me souviens bien
elle a débouché sur un rapport demandé à
gilles carez qui lui même a établi un
certain nombre de propositions le
rapport reposait sur un diagnostic
simple les ressources fiscales qui
servent à la fois alimenté aujourd'hui
le budget la société du grand paris et
surtout à prévoir l'amortissement de la
dette qu'elles constituent ses
ressources fiscales étaient
insuffisantes pour permettre d'envisager
l'amortissement complet de cette dette
la proposition les propositions du
rapport de gilles carez ont donc
consisté à augmenter ce panier de
ressources
c'est ce qui a été fait dans des
proportions qui se situe aux alentours
de 150 millions d'euros dont il ne
m'appartient pas ici et aujourd'hui de
vous dire si elles sont suffisantes ou
non je constate simplement que la
soutenabilité du modèle d'amortissement
de la dette qui vous ailleurs présenter
régulièrement à la suite de ces épisodes
qui présentait régulièrement au
parlement
dans ce cadre cette soutenabilité a été
prise en compte de manière énergique
passé de 500 millions d'euros de
recettes
à presque 750 c'était un effort majeur
un an un autre mot si vous me le
permettez sur cette question du modèle
financier
je voudrais souligner combien je pense
judy
monsieur judicieuse par dans la
stratégie de pré financement par
l'emprunt qui a été validé par le
conseil de surveillance sur proposition
du directoire
il s'agit en effet de profiter d'un
contexte de taux historiquement faibles
sans rentrer à nouveau dans les détails
cette stratégie de préfinancement qui
doit être continuée avec une gestion de
dette qui doit être également travaillé
cette stratégie là est également de
nature à permettre de favoriser la
soutenabilité du modèle notamment en
permettant une réduction des frais
financiers qui pèsent sur le bouclage
global du projet vous avez évoqué
monsieur le président la nécessité de
progrès à accomplir avec un certain
nombre des partenaires transports de la
région
je crois savoir que là aussi depuis
quelques années depuis deux ou trois ans
a été mis en place un système de
concertation permanente en particulier
avec ile-de-france mobilité je ne peux
pas porter un jugement sur ce
fonctionnement avant de l'avoir observé
moi même je ne peux dire qu'une chose
qui revient à une partie des propos que
j'ai tenus pour commencer c'est que
comme vous l'avez compris je n'imagine
pas que ce projet puisse être piloté au
niveau qui sera le mien sans un souci
permanent sans une question permanente
de son utilité finale et donc de la
manière dont il sera exploité et donc de
la relation avec ceux qui seront chargés
de sa maintenance quand ce ne sera plus
la société du grand paris est évidemment
ceux qui sont chargés de l'exploitation
il serait complètement absurde de ne pas
se livrer à cette concertation en
permanence alors je ne sais pas vous
répondre sur le point de savoir si cette
relation était mauvaise et dans quelle
mesure elle s'est améliorée ce que je
ressens à la suite de mes bref échange
et la suite de ce que j'ai lu c'est que
là encore sur ce domaine aussi c'est
avec une grande prof
et sio nalisation que le sujet a été
pris en compte
je vous en dirai plus si je suis
confirmé dans quelques mois merci pour
ces explications merci pour recruter vos
propos je vais donner la parole à didier
mandelli merci président monsieur le
sans doute futur président je veux
nommer comme ça moi je n'ai pour ce qui
me concerne pas de doute sur votre
capacité à vous adapter en fonction de
parcours vous avez pu avoir
même si on peut effectivement être
surpris de de la non sous la décision de
changement rapide et moi j'ai plutôt
dans un premier temps une question de
candide je vous poserai trois questions
précises ensuite une question de candide
qui ne fréquentent pas évidemment les
arcanes du pouvoir de la haute
administration
comment comment on arrive à être
candidat est ce que est ce que vous avez
été volontaire ce qu'on vous a sollicité
j'imagine évidemment que c'est pas une
annonce pôle emploi qui vous a mené
jusqu'à nous donc j'aimerais savoir
comment quel est le processus
voilà même si on peut en avoir une idée
question de candice je répète en toute
innocence
ma première question concerne les jo
le grand paris express c'était des
arguments qui ont permis d'appuyer la
candidature de la ville de paris c'est
un préalable à mon sens pour les jo de
2024 le calendrier a déjà été revue à la
baisse en 2018
il est bouleversé bien sûr comme
beaucoup d'activités par la crise
sanitaire et donc la logistique et
l'attractivité de l'événement sont
aujourd'hui voilà en question par
rapport à vos décisions qui avaient pu
être prises et aux objectifs
quelles sont vos prévisions aujourd'hui
concernant l'état du chantier avec la
perspective des jo
selon vous il y aura-t-il des arbitrages
à effectuer afin de favoriser une ligne
en particulier et quelles pourraient
être les conséquences sur le bon
déroulement des jeux égard aux
engagements pris deuxième question la
feuille de route qui était signée par le
premier ministre 13 novembre 2018 après
la signature d'un contrat d'objectifs et
de performance
qu'on évoquait également dans le cadre
de l'album sur les questions de mobilité
ou sens large entre la gp et l'état
alors la commission des finances du
sénat plus relevées lors de ces travaux
qu'un tel contrat n'avait pas été
formalisé la signature d'un contrat de
performance figure table parmi vos
priorités
quel en serait le calendrier et on
regarde la crise sanitaire qu'elle
provisions devraient nécessairement
qu'il y aurait dans ce contrat mais
dernière question est plus technique et
dans le cadre de notre commission nous
les sujets d'économie circulaire nous
intéresse au plus haut point
la question porte sur les 48 millions de
tonnes de terres excavées pour
construire le grand paris express vous
pouvez vous nous parler du devenir de
ces des blés sachant que ce poste
représente 5% environ du coût du projet
peut être revue à la hausse et que seuls
45% sont valorisés à ce jour vous serez
valorisé à ce jour là une question un
peu plus technique jeu j'imagine que
vous n'avez pas forcément eu le temps de
regarder ça de près mais c'est un enjeu
considérable pour pour le territoire
puisque ça peut représenter plus de 20%
des volumes habituels en ile de france
voilà monsieur deux présidents futur et
puis c'est un enjeu important pour la
politique environnementale merci chers
collègues je vous donne la parole à
monsieur demi
merci au président seul président du
directoire pressenti j'ai deux questions
les attentes autour du grand paris
express sont fortes on le sait ce projet
représentait ou représente l'atout
transport des jeux olympiques de paris
avec des mises en service initialement
prévu pour 2024
mais ces lignes ne seront finalement pas
achevés dans les délais nécessaires ce
qui pourrait bien sûr avoir des
répercussions extrêmement fortes sur la
qualité des jeux compte tenu du flux
potentiellement très important de
spectateurs je sais qu'une
délocalisation des épreuves sportives
est d'ailleurs envisagé les transports
qui devait être un des atouts majeurs
des jeux de parts ou de paris pardon
vont ils finalement en devenir une
faiblesse voilà ça c'est la première
question je voulais poser
deuxième question qui n'a rien à voir
concerne les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire et les profondes mutations
sociales que connaissent les grandes
villes et en particulier paris
de nombreux parisiens ont déjà quitté la
capitale pour s'installer dans des
petites villes de proximité aujourd'hui
54 % des franciliens se déclare prêt à
partir s'installer dans une autre région
contre seulement 35% en 2019
les cadres parisiens quand elles sont 83
% à envisager une mobilité régionale à
long terme pour exercer leurs activités
c'est une étude que j'ai lu de
cadremploi d'il ya quelques semaines le
télétravail semble amené à perdurer même
quelques jours par semaine ce qui va
bien sûr modifié modifie déjà les
manières de vivre
l'éventualité de crise durable est à
prévoir comme l'a évoqué d'ailleurs
devant nous en commission le haut
commissaire au plan françois bayrou la
semaine dernière et dans ce cas
permettez moi une question aussi naïve
que celle de mon collègue mon délit mais
une question cash et provoque
faut-il continuer à construire dans
l'agglomération parisienne
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole monsieur jacques un merci
président monsieur monteil je vous ai
bien écoutez vous avez affirmé qu'il n'y
aurait pas de rupture dans le projet à
cette question que vous vous êtes posé
vous nous avez répondu clairement non
alors moi j'aurais presque qu'une
question à vous poser
il ya un schéma d'ensemble qui a été
adoptée à l'unanimité le 26 mai c'est
moi 2011 sera-t-il tenu
je précise cette question parce que il y
a quelques mois le ministre des
transports en juin 2020 avait annoncé le
report d'une partie des lignes 16 et 17
en tout cas la partie stratégique autour
de saint denis et du bourget la ligne
des jo
et puis il y a quelques jours presque le
11 janvier il a déclaré que a
il ya des scénarios alternatifs pour le
tronçon saint denis pleyel et le bourget
et là vous ne nous en avait pas parlé
alors êtes-vous magicien parce que moi
je ne comprends pas bien
l'équation est pour le dire avec humour
je suis agriculteur votre prédécesseur a
dit que l'ue n'avait pas la capacité à
faire pousser du blé en sibérie je n'ai
pas entendu dans votre cv que vous aviez
cette capacité là mais aidez moi à lever
1 1
mystère puisqu'il va falloir trouver des
variables d'ajustement dans le
calendrier dans les financements
où sont elles alors que votre
prédécesseur a engagé une stratégie
d'irréversibilité en engageant presque
tous les travaux en les finançant
l'ensemble des marchés publics quelle
est la variable d'ajustement de ce plan
étonnant est ce que c'est la ligne 18
mai il ya saclay on n'imagine pas que
saclay ne soit pas desservis voilà puis
j'ai une toute dernière question sur les
financements c'est une question que je
pose depuis des années est-ce qu'il
n'est pas imaginable demain pour
financer le fonctionnement de regarder
du côté des plus values immobilières
privées celles qui se créent au droit
des gares gares financer avec de
l'argent public et qui générèrent c'est
plus values privées si ce n'est pas un
prélèvement sur les plus-values
immobilières privées est ce que c'est un
système de taxe foncière à cet endroit
merci beaucoup merci la parole est à
monsieur chevrollier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le
le candidat pressenti pour un grand
établissement la société du grand paris
qui a vocation à porter un projet
extrêmement structurants pour pour le
grand paris mais j'irai pour pour notre
pays
moi je voudrais vous interrogez vous
êtes ici devant la haute assemblée nous
représentons les les élus les élus de
communes aux départements nos régions
nos intercommunalités
comment vous envisagez la relation avec
les élus locaux qui siègent au sein de
cet établissement public qu'elle quel
modèle de gouvernance vous engager pour
mener à bien le projet structurant pour
notre pays merci merci je vous propose
monsieur vente et de répondre aux
questions posées par mes collègues merci
merci monsieur le président comme chacun
le sait il n'ya pas de questions naïves
alors je commencerai par celles qui ont
été ainsi présentés et en passant très
rapidement comment on est candidat à de
telles fonctions puisque certains
d'entre vous ont bien voulu plaisanter
quelque peu je vous dirais qu'on n'est
pas vraiment candidat de telles
fonctions ce poste de président du
directoire de la société du grand paris
va commencer à devenir confortable à
partir de 2030 je pense au paravant on
répond à cette demande parce qu'on a
comme moi passé trente ans de sa vie au
service de la chose publique the lady
est parce qu on croit que ça peut être
intéressant de rentrer dans une démarche
de construction positive
pardonnez-moi de je vais essayer de pas
trop le personnaliser et puis de ne pas
avoir une parole qui dépassent ma pensée
mais vous y vous imaginez aisément que
pour un haut fonctionnaire qui a
commencé sa carrière dans les années 90
le quotidien et plus tôt fait de
restrictions budgétaires restructuration
de système fonctionne en fonctionnant
difficilement réforme de l'état etc etc
c'est passionnant j'ai énormément
apprécié de travailler là dessus j'ai
essayé d'apporter ma pierre à cet
édifice mais il me plaît aussi de passer
outre ces difficultés dont une grande
partie de ma vie professionnelle a
consisté à essayer de les combler de
passer outre ces difficultés pour
démontrer que notre puissance publique
peut faire
voilà je n'ai pas été candidat je n'ai
pas pu refuser
alors la question du calendrier
bouleversé et des prévisions
je n'ai pas de prévisions je vais être
obligé de faire cette réponse à tous
ceux qui m'ont interrogé là-dessus
là encore je ne veux pas simplement
m'abriter derrière le fait que le temps
m'a manqué et les informations précises
m'ont manqué pour vous donner ces
éléments mais aussi vous dire que voilà
c'est un sujet assez difficile et c'est
une transparence suffisamment nécessaire
pour que j'évite de lancer dès cet après
midi
déchiffrage des plannings qui ne
reposeront sur rien que sur des
intuitions
je ne fonctionne pas à l'intuition j'ai
indiqué qu' un des grands atouts du
fonctionnement de cette société était sa
collégialité
je commencerai par m'appuyer dessus pour
faire mes propres analyses
alors en revanche ce que je peux dire
c'est que bien évidemment comme vous je
suis interrogatif sur ce que l'on peut
dire aujourd'hui sur un certain nombre
de ces projets quand même essayer de
lire un certain nombre de choses avant
de me présenter devant vous j'ai en
particulier lui beaucoup
d'interrogations qui porte sur un
certain nombre des ouvrages un certain
nombre des lignes notamment celles que
vous avez mentionné qui concerne les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques je vais
y revenir dans un instant je crois qu'il
serait tout à fait inapproprié de vous
donner à ce stade
une appréciation qui par définition ne
pourrait pas être définitive en revanche
je le dis ça va être une priorité
immédiate à mon arrivée que vérifier si
effectivement un certain nombre
d'éléments doivent être aujourd'hui
recalés je crois que ça fait rentrer
d'ailleurs dans un des aspects
particulièrement délicat du pilotage de
cette société du grand paris et du
projet la transparence est strictement
indispensables évidemment pas ici que je
dirais le contraire et j'en suis
d'ailleurs personnellement convaincu il
faut pas qu'elle ait pour contrepartie
le fait de tenir seconde par seconde
le calendrier des micro incident qui se
déroule sur chacun des 100 chantiers
bientôt 300 en cours sur le grand paris
express
il faut avoir des rendez-vous
périodiques aussi souvent que nécessaire
répondre aux convocations chaque fois
que nécessaire et donner tous les
éléments quand ils sont demandés mais il
ne faut pas non plus à mon sens en
arriver à tenir ce calendrier au jour le
jour est affiché en quelque sorte sur
les réseaux sociaux
l'évolution de chacun des incidents que
je mentionnais alors pour aller un tout
petit peu plus loin malgré tout et pour
répondre aussi aux autres questions qui
m'ont été posées
où en est-on en particulier sur ses
lignes crucial qui participent à la
candidature de notre pays
couronnée de succès pour les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
encore une fois je vous demande de
prendre ces propos comme ceux de
quelqu'un qui a commencé de se
renseigner le plus possible et qui veut
surtout vous montrer avec quel type de
méthode
je m'emploierai à travailler sur ces
questions complexes
plusieurs lignes sont concernées vous
l'avez mentionné l'une d'entre elles est
particulièrement critique
c'est le tronçon 16 17 entre pleyel et
le bourget ce n'est pas la seule et la
prolongation nord de la ligne 14
j'ai mentionné ce n'était pas par hasard
l'inauguration du 14 décembre dernier la
prolongation nord de la ligne 14
ainsi que la gare de pleyel sont deux
équipements absolument essentiel
déterminant pour les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
on en parle moins mais je peux vous dire
aussi que c'est déjà le cas et ça le
sera après mon arrivée l'énergie non
seulement de tous les agents de la
société du grand paris mais évidemment
de toutes les entreprises qui
participent à ces chantiers sera
exacerbée pour réussir ce rendez vous
pour ce tronçon
s'agissant du double tronçon 16-17 que
je mentionnais voilà la situation telle
que je la comprends si on repart des
annonces que faisait le premier ministre
en février 2018 et que j'ai déjà évoqué
à cette époque là ce tronçon était
présenté par le premier ministre comme
déjà tendues entre temps ça n'a échappé
à personne est intervenue la crise
pandémique
un môme malgré tout de cette crise
pandémique non pas pour vous dire des
choses que vous connaissez mieux que moi
mais simplement pour indiquer que les
conséquences de la crise pandémique sur
des chantiers tels que ceux du grand
paris sont si je puis dire concentriques
il ya évidemment les conséquences
immédiates de l'interruption des
chantiers qui a été décidé je crois dès
le 17 mars et qui a duré à peu près un
mois décision parfaitement judicieuse et
justifier inutile de le préciser mais
dans un processus de ce type processus
qui fait s'imbriquer des myriades de
décision cette interruption momentanée
finalement assez brève a forcément des
conséquences très lourdes et très
importante
je ne veux pas qualifier d' effet
papillon mais rate ou en tout cas qui
entraîne des désynchronisations de
chantier la nécessité de remettre en
place des processus
quand ils ont été interrompues à quoi
s'ajoutent d'ailleurs parce que nous ne
sommes pas sortis de la crise pandémique
des modalités de fonctionnement et de
travail qui sont qui subissent l'impact
de cette crise tout ceci aboutit d'après
les éléments dont je dispose a un retard
qui peut être évaluée selon les lignes
entre trois et neuf mois
ceci étant entendu sans mesures
correctrices
je ne sais pas aller plus loin je ne
sais pas aller plus loin à ce stade ce
que je sais en revanche dire c'est que
ce retard rang inatteignable l'objectif
sur ce tronçon 16-17 tel qu'il était
envisagé en 2018 alors comme vous l'avez
mentionné des solutions dégradées ont
été étudiés et sont encore à l'étude
je me trouve dans une situation un peu
inconfortable pour vous répondre parce
que ces études ne sont pas
définitivement rendue elles
nécessiteront très probablement pour
répondre clairement à votre question des
arbitrages ses arbitrages devront
devront prendre en compte ce n'est pas à
moi de le dire
enfin j'ai fait état de mon expérience
de l' arbitrage interministériel je peux
imaginer qu'elles prendront en compte
deux grandes séries de questions
premièrement l'importance extrême d'être
au rendez vous des jeux olympiques
deuxièmement regard de la qualité propre
de ces solutions dégrader les
inconvénients en chaîne que celle ci
porte pour l'ensemble du chantier
donc oui très probablement nous allons
avoir dans les semaines qui viennent
regardez en tout cas c'est ce que je
ferais si ma nomination est confirmée de
manière très précise
comment aborder ce sujet et pour
terminer très provisoirement sur ces
questions des lignes jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
je veux vraiment souligner qu' on ne
doit pas uniquement s'obnubiler sur la
question du tronçon du double tronçon 16
17 entre pleyel et le bourget
et que les autres rendez-vous en termes
de visibilité en terme d'accessibilité
sont également extrêmement important
monsieur le sénateur dans des lits vous
m'avez également demandé si
l'établissement d'un contrat d'objectifs
et de performance ferait partie de mes
priorités
pas de mes premières priorités pour vous
répondre de manière très directe jeu
j'obtiendrai de la part du premier
ministre je recevrai pardon de la part
du premier ministre une lettre de
mission
vous avez été un certain nombre à
mentionner la dernière lettre de mission
qui tient lieu de feuille de route c'est
un point important je dirais même
indispensable un contrat d'objectifs et
de performance comme tout contrat ceci
entre deux parties donc bien entendu que
j'évoquerai cette question c'est un
cadrage qui est ni confortable ni
inconfortable qui est effectivement
intéressant je serai mal venu à
considérer que ça n'est pas un outil
utile la maison d'origine passe
régulièrement de nombreux rapports pour
en rappeler l'importance voire
l'exigence donc c'est très important
comme je préfère répondre manière très
franche
ça n'est pas l'établissement du kop qui
sera au premier rang de mes priorités
personnelles en tout cas dans les
premières semaines de mon éventuelle
arrivée à la tête du directoire
vous avez évoqué également monsieur le
sénateur la question cruciale est
particulièrement lourde des déblais vous
avez compris ma sensibilité
environnementale construites de longue
date mais en particulier à la suite de
mon passage au secrétariat général du
ministère de la transition écologique
encore une fois j'en reste à la
dénomination actuelle passage qui m'a
permis non seulement d'embrasser un
certain nombre de ses sujets mais
également de rentrer en contact avec
nombre d'interlocuteurs qui me seront
très probablement précieux dans la suite
de ce parcours
alors vous l'avez dit autour de 45
millions de tonnes de déblais extrait
aujourd'hui près d'un tiers déjà extrait
je ne suis capable de vous dire que deux
choses qui sont les deux objectifs que
se fixe déjà et doit continuer de se
fixer la société du grand paris sur ce
sujet là avec les entreprises qui
conduisent les chantiers bien entendu
premièrement une extrême importance
attachée à la question des transports
chacun sait ici que c'est une question
très difficile
le fret fluvial sera privilégiée est
privilégiée chaque fois que possible ce
n'est pas toujours possible par
définition le fret ferroviaire dans une
région où les sillons je n'ai encore pas
étudié mais enfin je peux assez aisément
l'imaginer doivent s'arracher avec les
dents si vous me pardonnez la trivialité
de l'expression dans une région où la
question tout simplement des transports
ferroviaires justifie qu'on construise
un nouveau réseau je peux assez aisément
anticipé que l'utilisation ce moyen pour
le fret
les déblais aussi importante soit elle
et avec toute l'énergie que je mettrais
pour la faire progresser est une
question très difficile donc question du
transport d'abord il faut y attacher une
grande importance
question de la valorisation ensuite je
parle d'après ce que j'ai lu
l'objectif est de valoriser ces déblais
hauteur de 70%
c'est pour moi l'occasion d'utiliser un
terme que j'ai eu tort de ne pas
utiliser jusqu ici qui est celui
d'innovation j'aurais pu mettre ceci
dans l'adn de cette société du grand
paris et j'ai de nombreux éléments qui
me viennent d'ailleurs également de mon
expérience précédente de l'existence de
la sgp arriver à atteindre cet objectif
de valorisation à 70% est extrêmement
ambitieux il faut arriver à utiliser ces
déblais pour les remblais dans les
projets d'aménagement pour les
comblements de carrière pour des
expérimentations de l'innovation en
matière d'éco matériaux
c'est comme vous l'avez dit un enjeu
extrêmement important également sur le
plan financier
je ne pense pas qu'il sera possible de
progresser sans un vrai effort
d'innovation
je ne sais pas comment j'arriverai à le
faire progresser mais ce sera évidemment
au coeur de mes préoccupations
monsieur le sénateur de milly vous avez
mentionné les risques concernant les les
lignes des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques j'ai commencé d'y répondre
je n'y reviendrai pas vous avez
également posé une question que pour ne
rien vous cacher je me suis également
posé d'emblée lorsque j'ai commencé à
réfléchir sur ce que pourrait être mon
rôle est ce que pourrait être mon
appréhension du projet global
c'est la question beaucoup plus large de
des conséquences de la crise à la fois
sur sa sur la façon dont on peut faire
fonctionner la vie économique la vie
sociale la vie culturelle en période de
crise et sur les conséquences à plus
long terme qu'elle pourrait avoir sur
les modes de déplacement les modes de
travail etc
c'est évidemment une question très
importante
je dirais même passionnante je me
permets juste de dire que à la place qui
sera la mienne
il va falloir que aussi intéressante que
cette activité soit jeu j'abandonne
presque complètement la spéculation
intellectuelle encore une fois en 2030
je suis intéressé par toutes les études
que peuvent produire les sociologues les
ethnologues les spécialistes de ces
questions
je ne me sens pas capable de trouver des
réponses définitives
là dessus je dirai simplement en
répétant ce cette conviction que je vous
ai donné dans mon propos liminaire que
je ne pense pas quelles que soient ses
évolutions que la nécessité d'établir
des liens entre les territoires entre
les femmes et les hommes entre les zones
économiques entre
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque de la
première époque du grand paris les
clusters pardon de cet anglicisme dans
cette enceinte
je ne pense pas que cette nécessité va
disparaître je pense même en réalité
qu'elle va s'accroître
chacun d'entre nous expérimente
aujourd'hui au quotidien
le télétravail pour rester juste sur ce
sujet là et sans faire état de
d'expérience trop personnel un
désintérêt peut-être de cette période
que nous vivons aura été aussi d'en
montrer les limites
aujourd'hui tout le monde en est
conscient c'était déjà le cas
probablement auparavant mais aujourd'hui
de manière très importante
je ne crois donc pas que l'on doive
table et aujourd'hui sur un
bouleversement complet du mode de
fonctionnement humain si je puis dire
faut-il continuer à construire
j'ai envie là encore de vous répondre
non pas tout à fait par une boutade mais
par le fait que les chiffres que vous
mentionniez de intention de changer de
vie ces chiffres là me paraissent
également inspiré par un mode de
fonctionnement métropolitain ou
régionales qui n'est pas satisfaisant et
dont précisément le grand paris entend
permettre d'apporter des solutions
monsieur le sénateur jacques 1 vous avez
posé la question de la tenue du schéma
d'ensemble de 2011 alors en vous
interrogeant sur sur la variable
d'ajustement et on évoquant même
certaines lignes
là encore je veux être très clair je ne
vois pas comment en entamant cette
mission je pourrais avoir l'idée de
remettre en cause de quelque manière que
ce soit ce schéma d'ensemble
on a parlé de feuille de route adressé
par le premier ministre au président du
directoire
la feuille de route de la société du
grand paris à long terme
c'est ce schéma d'ensemble
et on n'en sortira pas la question de la
valorisation des plus values est
évidemment une question importante je
dirais que vous mmes un site et je vous
en remercie à sortir un peu de ma
compétence en y répondant comme je l'aï
indiqué au départ le modèle de
financement et notamment le modèle de
ressources d'origine fiscale et
déterminés par la loi
gilles carez pour le mentionner à
nouveau qui est un spécialiste bien
connue de ces questions et notamment
s'agissant du grand paris un
interlocuteur que j'avais dès l'époque
2009-2010 et je serais heureux de
retrouver envisager beaucoup de
possibilités de mon point de vue
strictement personnelle celle ci est
évidemment maïs riz serait là encore un
peu absurde de se priver de l'examiner
mais encore une fois j'essaierai si le
moment vient de participer à ses débats
à la place qui serait la mienne mais ce
ne sera pas à moi d'en décider
le sénateur chevrollier comment
j'envisage la relation avec les élus
locaux
alors je dirais à trois niveaux et avec
une méthode simple trois niveaux je ne
veux pas être trop institutionnel mais
il y a d'abord le conseil de
surveillance qui comprend des élus j'ai
établi un contact avec eux et je les ai
rencontrés il ya quelques heures
maintenant
à l'occasion du conseil de surveillance
de cet après midi qui donne un avis sur
ma candidature
il va de soi que le cadre institutionnel
du conseil de surveillance est
extrêmement important il ne saurait
suffire
je me suis engagé c'est pas difficile et
ça tombe sous le sens aller les
rencontrer le plus rapidement possible
il y a par ailleurs un comité
stratégique qui cette fois regroupe sous
la présidence du maire de vanves un très
grand nombre d'élus ils ont presque tous
les élus
concernés par le projet par une gare par
une ligne
et c'est là aussi cet organisme
cet organe pardon j'essaierai de
l'utiliser et de le faire vivre au
maximum mais c'est mon troisième point
est finalement ma méthode
je ne compte pas m'en tenir là je ne
sais pas travailler autrement qu'en
allant à la rencontre des gens
paradoxalement sur un projet de cette
ampleur je ne crois pas en tout cas je
n'ai pas l'ambition de le maîtriser dans
ses moindres détails je ne pense pas que
ce soit le rôle du président du
directoire de la société du grand paris
que d'être capable au débotté d'avoir
une réponse sur la situation précise du
tunnelier x à tel endroit de la ligne
entre clichy montfermeil et noisy-champs
revanche je pense qu'il y a le maintien
de cette garantie cohérence qui rentre
dans les fonctions du directoire et de
son président et la capacité à maintenir
également en permanence le niveau de
confiance qui est indispensable à la
réussite du projet et que j'ai évoqués
en commençant celui ci pour moi passe
aussi par des relations
interpersonnelles je m'emploierai à
l'est nous est le plus rapidement
possible et à les faire vivre
j'ai sans doute oublié des questions
monsieur le président si c'est le cas
pardonner mans est ce qu il a été
répondu à toutes vos questions
oui bien d'un merci merci pour pour ses
réponses merci pour votre engagement et
si votre nomination est entériné
j'espère que vous ferez pas comme les
autres candidats que vous resterez le
temps délégué parce que la mission vaut
bien d'avoir un peu de temps devant soi
pour pour y travailler
merci merci monsieur le président merci
à tous
[Musique]